pasada la una de la tarde un hombre de
31 años embistió con su vehículo a un
grupo de personas que aguardaba la
llegada del autobús esto cerca del
asentamiento judío de Ramón en Jerusalén
este ocupado entre las víctimas mortales
hay un niño de 6 años que fue declarado
muerto en esa misma parada de bus y un
joven ventañero que falleció momentos
después ya en el hospital este ataque a
priori intencional ha sido definido por
el gobierno de coalición israelí como
uno de carácter terrorista que como se
ha confirmado ha sido llevado a cabo por
un palestino con ciudadanía israelí
también residente de Jerusalén este que
murió tras el atropello producto del
disparo de un policía que estaba en el
lugar sin ninguna dilación el Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netanyahu ha
ordenado el cierre y la demolición de su
vivienda en una medida habitual pero que
Bajo su gobierno de coalición se está
efectuando de una forma inmediata
Asimismo netanyahu ha exigido un
refuerzo de las medidas de seguridad en
Jerusalén pero precisamente suministro
la seguridad nacional y tamar que acudió
hasta Ramón hasta el lugar de los hechos
ha dicho que estos no suficiente y ha
vuelto a reclamar la instauración de la
pena de muerte en concreto la Silla
eléctrica para aquellos que cometan
actos terroristas en Israel Mientras
tanto los grupos jamat y la yihat
islámica Palestina celebraron este
atropello pero no se adjudicaron su
autoría este hecho es uno más en una
violencia constante aquí pero
intensificada en desde el inicio de 2023
que ya deja al menos 43 palestinos
muertos y nueve israelíes muertos